das bundeskriminalamt warnt vor neuer
vor mehr gewalt in deutschland wegen der
hohen energiepreise wegen der immer
höheren belastungen für millionen
deutsche wut die in gewalt umschlägt und
vor allen dingen radikale die diese
energie krise ausnutzen könnten für ihre
zwecke politisch motivierte gewalt vor
allem gegen energiekonzerne und gegen
infrastruktur gegen kraftwerke und häfen
bild liegt exklusiv die neue
lageeinschätzung des bundeskriminalamtes
dazu vor und die hat es tatsächlich in
sich schauen wir einmal reine dieses
papier des bundeskriminalamtes da steht
dass die sorge wachsen vor mehr
politisch motivierter gewalt vor
radikalen reaktionen zum beispiel auf
die vermehrte nutzung von
kohlekraftwerken dann wird das bka noch
konkreter es gehe um aktionen gegen die
großen energiekonzerne die zunehmend als
so heißt es in diesem papier krisen
profiteure bezeichnet würden das bka
nimmt vor allem linke gruppierungen in
den blick und warnt vor aktionen gegen
kernkraftwerke darüber wollen wir
sprechen hier im studio mit dem chef der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft mit rainer
wendt ich grüße sie hallo ich alarmiert
sie dieses papier des
bundeskriminalamtes nicht wirklich wir
rechnen seit langem mit einem meisten
herbst und wie man nicht das wetter
sondern damit dass viele demonstrative
aktion aus unterschiedlichen anlässen
aufeinander treffen und unsere
bereitschaft kollegin in der
bereitschaftspolizei sehr gefordert sein
werden gefordert man bereitet sich jetzt
schon darauf vorher wie macht man das
genau unter anderem dadurch dass die
bundespolizei kräfte anfordert denn wir
müssen leider feststellen schon in der
ersten jahreshälfte hat es zu wenig
gegeben eine unterdeckung von bis zu
3000 leuten unter dick und bedeutet dass
die länder die zuständig sind für
versammlungen kräfte anfordern unter
anderem der bundespolizei und trotzdem
im durchschnitt über 1700 leute zu wenig
haben am wochenende um die demonstration
die jetzt schon da sind die dann
zusammentreffen da gibt es ja corona
energie und dann kommen auch noch ein
paar fußballspiele dazu und vieles
andere mehr das was jetzt und da ist hat
zu einer unterdeckung geführt dass er
hat beispielsweise die bundespolizei
zehn neue hundertschaften will zehn neue
hundertschaften aufstellen 1240 leute an
ort als einstellungsmöglichkeit 500 sich
leider nur genehmigt worden dass es geht
voran aber es geht zu langsam die
demonstrationen sind das eine steht in
dem papier sowohl von links als auch von
rechts und dann geht es vor allen dingen
auch um den schutz der kritischen
infrastruktur also kraftwerke helfen zb
ist da der schutz schon hochgefahren
worden ja der schutz wird permanent
hochgefahren je nach lagebeurteilung die
gefährdungsbeurteilung wird ja in den
ländern von dem landeskriminalamt bei
den jeweiligen objekten gemacht und da
wird da geht es aber nicht nur darum
dass dort person personal steht und
diese dinger bewacht das kennen wir ja
auch von früher von kraftwerken wir
kennen ja auch die auseinandersetzung
kohlekraftwerke in nordrhein-westfalen
und anderswo es geht aber auch vor allen
dingen um die cyber-angriffe auf solche
infrastruktur das ist noch viel
gefährlicher denn dann können die durch
solche terroristischen akten gelegt
werden und dann werde der schaden
unermesslich
man braucht auch dringend mehr personal
an sie gerade gesagt man braucht auch
mehr polizistinnen und polizisten einen
job den ich unbedingt beliebt ist wo es
auch schwer fällt nachwuchs zu bekommen
man kommt in gefährliche situationen oft
bekommt man für seine arbeit nicht genug
respekt haben sie die sorge dass ich gar
nicht genug beamtinnen und beamte finden
werden um den nachschub auch wirklich am
laufen zu halten glücklicherweise ist
der polizeiberuf einer der beliebtesten
in deutschland unter jungen menschen bei
jungen frauen und männern die von der
schule abgehen immer noch auf platz eins
in der liste der traumberufe aber es
gibt zu wenig geeignete denn wir können
sie ja nicht alle einstellen
grundsätzlich gilt dass wir acht bis
zehn erst einmal testen müssen bevor wir
eine oder einen einstellen deshalb bin
ich dankbar für den werbeblock wenn
junge leute wenn es junge leute gibt die
clever sind die natürlich auch mutig
sind aber vor allem den clever sind
diesen interessanten beruf zu ergreifen
ich würde immer wieder polizisten denn
die polizisten werden in diesem herbst
in diesem winter umso mehr gebraucht das
sagt das bundeskriminalamt eben in
dieser neuen lage einschätzung die bild
exklusiv vorliegt da ist ein bisschen
schwammig die rede von linken
gruppierungen beispielsweise auch von
gewalt politisch motivierter gewalt
möglichen straftaten aus dem rechten
milieu können sie ein bisschen konkreter
werden also wenn wir mit blick auf diese
energiekrise straftaten in den blick
nehmen von wem könnten diese straftaten
ausgehen der linke und rechte gruppe
schaukeln sich derzeit gerade hoch das
sehen wir jetzt schon bei den motors
themas die muss wo rechte auch
gruppierungen extremistische
gruppierungen versuchen diese proteste
die er berechtigte proteste sind der
häufig man darf er gegen korona
maßnahmen der bundesregierung
demonstrieren man darf auch gegen die
energiepolitik demonstrieren das sind
nicht alles extremisten sondern das sind
besorgte bürgerinnen und bürger aber
linke und rechte extremisten versuchen
natürlich das für ihre zwecke zu
instrumentalisieren
um die stimmung im land insgesamt hoch
zu schaukeln dann muss die polizei
dazwischen stehen einerseits
andererseits verpflichtet uns auch dass
die die gerichtsbarkeit die gerichte
verpflichten uns auch dafür zu sorgen
dass die sich sehen und hören können die
gegenseitigen demonstranten das ist eine
schwierige gemengelage
nimmt die einsatzleiter in die
verantwortung die einsatzkräfte die
dazwischen stehen müssen und deshalb
noch einmal es wird vermutlich an heißer
herbst werden für die einsatzkräfte wir
bereiten uns darauf viele szenarien vor
wenn sie sich daher von der politik
genug abgeholt auch genug geschützt dass
die einsatzkräfte ihre arbeit so machen
können wie sie auch machen wollen und
gleichzeitig könnte man ja auch die
politik mehr in die pflicht nehmen und
zu sagen beugen wir doch dem vor wir
sehen was da droht fühlen sie dass das
im moment genug gemacht hat also die
wertschätzung durch die politik lässt zu
wünschen übrig
sieben polizistinnen und polizisten die
wir tausendfach an jedem wochenende in
den einsatz schicken müssen sich dann
die woche über wirklich dämliche
diskussion um angeblich strukturellen
rassismus in der polizei gefallen lassen
und ähnliches das heißt die politik
arbeitet sich an der polizei ab und am
wochenende lässt sie die republik durch
dieselbe polizei schützen das lässt zu
wünschen übrig was die schutzausstattung
angeht der polizei hat sich eine menge
getan in der vergangenheit unsere
bereitschaftspolizei ist das immer
wieder ist eine der besten der welt
unsere kolleginnen und kollegen sind top
ausgebildet gut ausgestattet und auch
hoch motiviert das heißt man kann sich
auf die verlassen dank an rainer wendt
der chef der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft zu dem neuen papier
des bundeskriminalamtes das war vor mehr
gewalt im zuge dieser tiefen
energiekrise danke danke schön
[Musik]